[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde Raymond Haron une pensée phare
pour éclairer les conflits du monde
Raymond hararon est né en 1905 il s'est
éteint en
1983 peu avant la chute du mur de Berlin
et l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique
c'est l'un des plus féconds observateurs
des relations internationales il est
l'auteur d'une œuvre considérable sur un
20e siècle qui mis en exerg les
idéologies meurtrières du communisme et
du nazisme deux religions séculières sur
la classe et la race qui cause des
ravages des ravages pardon humains à
l'égal d'un Henry Kissinger pour penser
diplomatie et stratégie sur les pas de
clos Vitz pour démêler guerre et pai
Raymont Haron chercha à comprendre le
monde plutôt qu'à le transformer selon
des fantasmes bien pensants et
révolutionnaires doté d'un esprit de
raison et de valeur libéral cet écrivain
journaliste et conseiller des grands de
ce monde dont le général de Gaulle ne
s'est quasiment jamais trompé sur
l'intégibilité événementielle du 20e
siècle qu'on en juge étudiant en
Allemagne il perçoit d'emblé ce que sera
la barbarie naasie il est contre le
compromis honteux et boiteux muniois en
1938 il rejoint la France libre en 1940
il met en garde contre l'idéologie
communiste et stalinienne il est
pro-européen convaincu il soutient la
réconciliation
franco-allemande le marché commun il se
rallie à la
décolonisation il résiste même à
l'anti-américanisme de la gauche
française et même du général de Gaulle
bref des choix judicieux dont il fait
l'humbleux je le cite je n'ai jamais
justifié
l'injustifiable pour raison dialectique
avec mes invités nous allons chercher à
comprendre ce parcours sans
faute Nicolas bavrez vous êtes avocat
politologue chroniqueur au point et au
Figaro Jean-Claude Casanova vous êtes
économiste professeur des universités et
directeur de la revue
commentairire Sylvie Berman vous êtes
ambassadrice de France et vous avez
occupé quelquesuns des plus beaux postes
diplomatique pierre Lelouche vous êtes
ancien ministre
esséiste Pierre Manan vous êtes
philosophe vous avez été l'assistant de
Raymond Haron au Collège de
[Musique]
France alors pour Raymond Haron vous
venez de voir sa citation la diplomatie
des État démocratique obéit à d'autres
règles que la diplomatie des états
totalitaires hors de tout manquéisme
idéologique démocratie et totalitarisme
s'opposent radicalement d'où lui vient
cette sagacité politique plutôt qu'à son
époque l'air du temps épousait plutôt le
romantisme sartrien de la violence dont
on sait à quel point il contribua au
brouillage de l'histoire Nicolas bavrez
en fait comme vous l'avez dit ce qui est
assez extraordinaire chez Aaron ces
trois choses d'abord une œuvre qui est
immense et qui traverse les frontières
des disciplines à la fois philosophique
historique une œuvre de relation
internationale de stratégie et de
sociologie il y a ce que vous avez
rappelé c'est-à-dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui ne s'est pratiquement jamais trompé
qui a toujours été du côté de la liberté
et ce qui répond à votre question c'est
que ça a été quelqu'un qui a été
extrêmement courageux et qui a payé
durement durement ses choix donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a compris beaucoup
mieux que d'autres l'histoire du 20e
siècle c'est sûrement le le choc de de
ce qu'il a découvert en Allemagne avec
le le nazisme qui a été très important
il est allé en Allemagne en 1930 il part
socialiste pacifiste et il voit arriver
Hitler au pouvoir et là il comprend
d'emblé que ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est quelque chose qui va faire
basculer
l'histoire de l'Europe et il est d'emblé
opposant donc au nazisme et il abandonne
son pacifisme et à partir de cette
expérience fondatrice il découvre aussi
la la la sociologie allemande de de
l'histoire et il va concevoir à partir
de saette thèse le système intellectuel
qui va ensuite le guider et qui en fera
un peu le professeur d'hygiène
intellectuelle des Français c'est-à-dire
un système où il s'agit de d'abord de de
comprendre de regarder les faits comme
ils sont de prendre l'histoire de
l'interpréter et de s'engager dans
l'action et et ça sera ensuite la
fameuse position du spectateur engagé et
c'est ce qu'il a utilisé face à Hitler
et c'est pour ça qu'il a été antimuniois
c'est pour ça qu'il s'est retrouvé au
côté du général de Gaulle à Londres et
c'est aussi pourquoi contrairement à
l'essentiel de l'intelligencia française
il est le seul finalement avec André
merau dans les grands intellectuels il
est le seul à être d'emblé au moment où
la guerre froide ce nous c'est-à-dire 46
47 il est le seul à être du côté de il
est le seul à être du côté de la liberté
alors vous êtes tous d'accord là-dessus
il s'est jamais trompé sur Claude
Casanova al comparé à Maler il s'est
jamais trompé parce que Maler ne devient
raisonnable que dans la dernière partie
de sa vie mais le par exemple Maler
approuve le PACT javano soviétique ce
qui est quand même discutable mais le
sur les grandes questions politiques non
ne s'est jamais trompé et même il ne
s'est jamais trompé avant les autres par
exemple sur la nécessité d'indépendance
de l'Algérie il l'a dit très tôt et très
clairement et très justement oui c'est
votre avis Sylvie Berman pierre Lelouche
oui tout à fait en plus il a était très
courageux parce que comme l'a dit
Nicolas bavrz la tendance c'était plutôt
à gauche à l'époque pour ne pas dire
gauchiste d'abord le le soutien à
l'Union soviétique et puis le soutien
également au Maoist mais dans son combat
avec Sartre on se souvient que certains
avaient dit mieux vaut avoir tort avec
Sartre que d'avoir raison avec Raymond
Haron mais tous les euh les étudiants en
Scien politiqu et ensuite les diplomates
puisque je représente ici aussi la la
diplomatie finalement ont été ne sont
pas nés gaoliens ou aroniens mais elles
sont devenu de toute façon parce que
effectivement c'est non pas le monde tel
que on le désire mais le monde tel qu'il
est et une analyse des situations à côté
de à partir de de ceela ouais pierre
Lelouche bon moi j'ai eu la chance de de
le rencontrer malheureusement trop de
façon trop courte pu c'était les quatre
dernières années de sa vie mais il a
joué un rôle extrêmement important dans
ma vie puisque je revenais de mes études
aux États-Unis me suis aperçu que
personne voulait de moi puis mon diplôme
américain valait rien il valait tout
recommencer j'avais pas envie envie
d'aller à Lena et il m'a pris avec lui à
la Maison des sciences de l'homme et il
avait une espèce de générosité
formidable à l'égard d'un jeune tous les
mois nous déjeunions récamiier et on
parlait politique et politique
internationale et ce que j'adorit chez
lui et Nicolas l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure c'est non seulement le goût de
la liberté et de la réalité des faits
mais surtout l'extraordinaire clarté de
l'exposé et ce que nous rêvons tous
d'obtenir de commencer sur une feuille
blanche et d'amener le lecteur à une
compréhension des faits et à la bonne
conclusion et ça il savait faire uneune
façon extraordinaire et la richesse de
sa formation philosophe
sociologue moi je ne connaissais qu'une
petite
partie du haaron celui des armes
nucléaires et de la stratégie où il
était à l'égal des plus grands aux
États-Unis Bernard Brod et cetera à
l'époque l'un des pirres de ce qui a été
la doctrine de la dissuasion de la
négociation sur les armes stratégique
euh moi il m'a tout appris euh ce que
j'avais appris aux États-Unis coloré par
Aaron il a donc joué un rôle très très
important dans ma vie puis après ça a
été la création de l'ffer Jean-Claude
s'en souvient et puis après j'ai
bifurqué ce qu'il a jamais voulu faire
lui et c'était l'une de nos
conversations euh pourquoi être un
spectateur seulement et pas un acteur de
la politique moi j'ai bu furqué je pense
qu'il m'aurait on va on va en parler
alors vous pierre Manan vous l'avez
connu également comme étudiant si je
puis dire en tout cas vous avez été son
assistant qu'est-ce qui vous a conduit à
être son assistant c'est vous qui avez
choisi ou c'est lui qui vous a choisi
euh
je ce ce qui m'a je ne sais pas répondre
directement à votre question mais ce qui
m'a euh frappé chez Aaron et ce qui me
continue de me frapper c'est euh le
sérieux avec lequel il considère la
politique parce que c'est très rare
contrairement à ce qu'on pense tout le
monde à son avis sur la politique tout
le monde s'enthousiasme pour ou contre
mais en fait les gens ne s'intéressent
pas véritablement à à ce dont il s'agit
si vous prenez Sartre il a dit n'importe
quoi souvent n'importe quoi avec plus ou
moins de Briot mais fondamentalement
pourquoi c'est qu'il ne s'est jamais
réellement intéressé aux questions
politiques il prenit des positions qui
déduisaient d'une certaine philosophie
morale générale une certaine
métaphysique phénoménologie tout ce
qu'on voudra mais la chose politique ne
l'intéressait pas
Aaron depuis le début il s'est il a
regardé avec une attention et une
humilité extrême de quoi il s'agissait
et donc il a il nous donne à sentir
d'abord la le caractère déterminant de
la chose politique ça c'est quelque
chose que Aaron a en commun avec les
grands philosophes politiques des en
commun avec les Grecs ce qui donne forme
à la vie commune c'est d'abord la chose
politique et que la chose politique a sa
propre noblesse n'est-ce pas c'est pas
les gens en général on ont tendance à à
faire tomber la morale sur la politique
mais il y a une une morale de la
politique et qui est d'une certaine
façon une des plus difficiles parce que
le politique doit prendre en compte des
paramètres très différents et faire
tenir ensemble des paramètres le
philosophe que vous êtes comment
explique-t-il cette relation intime
qu'il avait avec la chose
politique dont vous êtes en train de
parler je crois que il est c'était la
passion du citoyen c'était il il avait
une passion de citoyen et une une je
dirais une impartialité de de de de
philosophe si vous voulez et c'est la la
jonction des deux entre la la partialité
inévitable la passion du citoyen et
l'impartialité du philosophe qu'il
réussissait à à combiner oui Jean-Claude
Casanova et tout tout se combine chez
lui à partir du moment où il choisit
comme vocation la réflexion sur
l'histoire et que l'histoire c'est à la
fois le passé le présent et que le passé
le présent détermine la façon dont on
voit l'avenir il fait les deux choses
qui sont très importantes en politique
c'est qu'il ne cesse pas d'étudier de
1933 à la fin de sa vie il a étudié
toutes les grandes questions qui sont
nécessaires au jugement politique et il
pouvait parler de la balance des
paiements et des taux changes flexibles
de la dissuation nucléaire du système
internationale de l'Union soviétique et
cetera et en deuxième lieu il avait une
caractéristique très importante qui lui
venait d'un incident de jeunesse c'est
que quand il prenait une quand il
critiquait une position politique il
disait en même temps ce qu'il serait
nécessaire ou possible de faire
c'estàdire que ces critiques étaient
toujours accompagné des des autres voix
poss possible qui lui paraissait plus
judicieuse ou plus raisonnable oui
Nicolas pour prolongé ce qui vient
d'être dit par Jean-Claude Casanova
quand il était en Allemagne il est
revenu et il y a par l'intermédiaire
dans du frère dansre ses amis il a eu
rendez-vous avec Monsieur Paganon qui
était sous-secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires étrangères et qui a interrogé
sur l'Allemagne et donc il a fait un
superbe exposé sur la situation de
l'Allemagne et ensuite monsieur Paganon
qui était pas forcément un aigle
politique lui a dit mais alors si vous
étiez à ma place qu'est-ce que vous
feriez et là il s'est retrouvé quoi et
il a toujours retenu ça avec l'idée que
le euh quand on parle de politique euh
il faut ce ce ce qui a été dit
c'est-à-dire euh il faut évidemment
analyser les faits analyser la situation
mais ensuite se mettre à la place des
des acteurs et effectivement chez Haron
il y a cette rencontre entre un vrai
projet intellectuel qui était de
d'analyser de comprendre euh l'histoire
telle qu'elle se fait en en prenant en
compte toutes les dimensions économiques
stratégiques euh politique évidemment
mais aussi de de comprendre du point de
vue des acteurs et et de s'engager
ensuite donc de prendre toujours le
risque de l'engagement oui oui mais de
s'engager sans aller jusque dans
l'action politique je me souviens de
cette conversation avec lui où je lui
disais avec beaucoup d'admiration dans
les yeux mais pourquoi vous vous êtes
contenté d'un rôle de spectateur même
engagé mais de spectateur de
commentateur et jamais de de de je vais
citer Kissinger pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
devenu le Kissinger de la France aurait
besoin de cette de cela en France die
sais que faire de mauvais commentaires
sur le présent mais et et là il me dit
ah non non non non c'est deux choses
très différentes l'analyse et l'action
et en me disant ça je sens dans ses yeux
quand même le regret c'estd que il y a
l'action mais c'est l'action des idées
pas l'action par rentrer dans l'arine
politique et se cololleter avec toute la
difficulté de l'action politique celle
qu'on apprend quand on est dans l'arine
et et on s'aperçoit combien il est
difficile d'aller du point A au point B
mais lui il savait au moins donner les
moyens d'action politique après il
fallait être écouté mais il a jamais
voulu rentrer dans un rôle actif de
conseiller vous avez dit tout à l'heure
dans l'introduction il a été le
conseiller du président ou du général de
Gaul je parle sur le contrôle de SAF il
a influencé de Gaul sur la
Atlantique on a des preuves moment du
RPF oui oui mais enfin il a pas été au
quotidien à ses côtés sur ces dossiersl
ouais piman non je voudrais je voulais
je vais vous laisser la parole mais je
voudrais aussi que vous prolongiez le
débat parce que dans cette émission on
va faire des alerretour entre Raymond
araron et son siècle et le siècle
d'aujourd'hui alors la question que je
voudrais vous poser et vous répondrez
par ailleurs à cette dissociation entre
l'action et la pensée à son époque déjà
André mallerot et George Semprun poinai
la menace islamiste et Georg Semprun
disait même dès les années 60 qu'il
s'agissait d'un totalitarisme vert qu'il
mettait à l'égal du stalinisme et du
fascisme qu'on aurait pensé Aaron qui
intégra ça a été souligné par
Jean-Claude Casanova notamment et
Nicolas bavrz dans sa pensée un spectre
très large de connaissance notamment
religieuse économique et sociologique
alors là je je je vais vous répondre
tout de suite que je ne vais peux pas
vous répondre je nai je je ne sais pas
ce que Aaron dirait ce dont je me
souviens c'est que dans les premières
pages d'un
texte particulièrement intéressant
d'Aron des années 60 l'AUE de l'histoire
universelle il dit que
finalement ce qui sépare le plus les
hommes c'est peut-être l'idée qu'ils se
font les uns et les autres du sacré donc
il et il ne va il ne commande pas
au-delà mais on peut penser que euh des
dès ce moment-là en quelque sorte il
envisageait euh les les les distances
entre les les formes de vie collective
après tout c'était un grand lecteur de
de Weber Weber a été particulièrement
intéressé au rôle des grandes religions
dans la mise en forme des des des des
des vies humaines donc je pense que les
circonstances l'auraient conduit à s'y
intéresser mais quand à dire ce qu'il
quand à imaginer ce qu'il en aurait dit
je je ne sais pas je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait spécialement apprécié la
l'utilisation du terme de totalitarisme
pour définir les problèmes qui se qui se
posent à nous avec l'islam mais enfin ça
c'est vous vouliez dire un mot sur la
dissociation oui parce que prx ce qu'a
dit Pierre Lelouch euh bien sûr il n'est
pas passé dans l'action mais il avait
sur la politique le point de vue de
l'action il considérait que la politique
c'était d'abord des hommes agissant d'où
l'importance qu'il accordait au
commandement ça m'a frappé en lors de la
thèse d'un de mes mes étudiants qui
rassemblait des des éléments sur la
politique d'Aron et j'ai j'ai mesuré à
quel point la notion de commandement est
fréquente dans l'œuvre d'Aron or cette
notion a complètement disparu de la
compréhension de la chose politique la
démocratie ne s'intéresse qu'à
l'obéissance à l'obéissance à la loi
l'obéissance légitime mais que la
politique soit fait d'abord par des
hommes qui commandent et que elle est
déterminée par ceux qui commandent et
par le style de leur commandement c'est
une expression d'Aron ça c'est un c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est spécifique
et c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
il est si pénétrant sur la chose
politique alors on revient au
fondamentalisme vert Jean-Claude
Casanova pour poursuiv ce que dit Pierre
je je commencerai par une anecdote en
novembre 1954 j'étais étudiant et j'ai
demandé à Aaron son avis sur un livre et
il m'a dit les livres de professeur sont
parfois utiles pour préparer les examens
mais si on s'intéresse à la politique il
y a deux livr essentiel c'est la guerre
du Péloponèse de tusdide et c'est la
Politique d'Aristote et si je me réfère
à ces deux livres et à la citation
d'araron vous avez mis au début Aaron
trouverit comme parfaitement idiot
aujourd'hui de considérer que les
différences de régimes n'ont pas
d'importance que les États sont des
monstres froids qui ont entre eux des
rapports mystérieux et que ne
comprennent que les réalistes en fait si
vous voulez la différence entre Poutine
et l'Occident c'est que la nature du
régime politique russe est
fondamentalement différent des
démocraties et la différence qui se pose
dans le Moyen-Orient c'est que l'Islam
est en situation complexe à l'égard de
l'Occident dans lequel le ressentti
sentiment se mêle à d'autres autrement
dit que pour comprendre la politique il
faut aussi réfléchir sur la nature des
régimes politiques sur la différen entre
les religions sur les idées des hommes
oui Nicolas bavrez vous alors il y a un
événement sur lequel Aaron a s'est
prononcé et qui montrait que il a bien
compris la dimension religieuse c'est la
révolution iranienne de 79 parce qu'à
l'époque beaucoup de gens ont pensé que
c'était la suite de la poussée de
l'Union soviétique euh et donc lui n'a
pas du tout adhéré à à cette analyse il
a bien vu que c'était une une révolution
religieuse et Aaron a toujours bien fait
la et à cette occasion le départ entre
dans les les idéologies totalitaires il
avait utilisé
notamment à Londres la notion de ce
qu'il appelait les religions séculières
parce que c'était la dimension de la foi
la déification de la race ou de la
classe mais il a toujours bien fait la
différence entre les religions
séculières et et les religions
régulières mais il n'a
jamais il n'a jamais avancé l'idée que
les religions régulières n'auraient plus
de poids dans la politique et de toute
manière il y a un autre il y a un autre
dossier international si je puis dire
sur lequel il a écrit sur lequel il
l'avait évidemment perçu c'est le c'est
le Moyen-Orient sur lequel on ne peut
pas et on le voit évidemment aujourd'hui
il y a pas d'analyse possible ni de
construction de solution si on ne prend
pas en compte également évidemment le
le fait religieux alors Sylvie Berman
avec vous voyons un aspect diplomatique
Haron a dit dans guerre épée que le
déclin historique des nations
européennes a été précipité par les
guerre du 20e siècle est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce jugement et est-ce
qu'il était pessimiste toute sa vie sur
la possibilité que l'Europe devienne une
Europe puissance alors pour l'Europe
puissance c'était euh évidemment un
petit peu prématuré mais il était
profondément européen néanmoins même
s'il croyait à la souveraineté euh des
états euh il euh il pensait que euh
l'Europe avait euh un rôle à jouer
maintenant euh est-ce que les guerres du
20e siècle c'est-à-dire cell qui l' a
connu et qui sont les euh les pires ont
précipité le déclin je crois que après
ces guerres il y a eu au contraire
l'espoir d'un renouveau quand euh ce
sont les Occidentaux qui ont créé les
les Nations Unies dont il parlent assez
peu hein si je me souviens bien
puisqu'il croit à la puissance
essentiellement des des états et non pas
à une instance internationale puis qu'à
l'époque c'était le la guerre froide et
que l'ONU était paralysé comme comme il
est paralysé aujourd'hui donc il croyait
plutôt effectivement au rôle des des
nations mais encore une fois ces guerres
ont été ravageuses pour pour l'Europe
mais justement à partir de là les
Européens ont voulu construire un autre
système la réconciliation avec
l'Allemagne qu' qui a soutenu et un
système européen pierre lelouge vous
allez répondre là-dessus mais
prolongeant aussi la question sur ce
déclin de l'Europe est-ce qu'il faisait
un lien entre déclin de l'Europe et
décadence de
l'Occident autrement dit est-ce qu'il
Amarr l'Europe complètement Occident
complètement oui il faut quand même
rappeler que il meurt un an avant la
chite du mur de Berlin donc le monde qu'
a commmenté c'est un autre monde c'est
je le regarde presque avec nostalgie par
rapport à ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
et par rapport au chocs invraisemblabl
qui sont devant nous lui il avait
affaire à une Europe qui s'était suicidé
à deux à deux reprises au 20e siècle euh
il considérait avec beaucoup de réalisme
contre Sartre et bien d'autres et les
communistes que la solution c'était de
s'amarer aux États-Unis sinon sinon
l'Union soviétique prendrait la totalité
du continent et qu'il fallait éviter la
neutralisation de l'Allemagne et cetera
donc il prenait les les choses Réal
rappelez-vous le début des années 80 est
dominé par l'affaire des euromissiles si
les Russes l'avaient emporté à ce
moment-là l'Allemagne était neutralisée
on a tenu bon jusqu'au moment où le mur
tombe l'Union soviétique se désagrèche 2
ans après là on bascule dans toute fait
autre chose mais il n'est plus là pour
le commenter ce qui veut dire par
exemple que la montée de toutes sortes
d'autres problèmes comme l'islam qui
était j'allais dire couvert par les les
empires pendant la période de la guerre
froide beaucoup des problèmes que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec le fameux
Sud global la revendication le
révisionnisme venu du sud de l'islam et
d'autres choses n'existait pas pendant
la guerre froide il y avait deux empires
lui il disait carrément que il fallait
tenir tenir B face à l'Union soviétique
et il a défendu cette thèse de
l'alliance avec les États-Unis à
l'époque c'était pas franchement facile
parce que de GA lui il essayait de
dégager des marges d'indépendance pour
la diplomatie française entre les deux
blocs et puis vous avez toute une partie
de la classe politique française qui
était à fond anti-américaine et plutôt
pro soviétique donc il a tenu ce
discours de raison Nicolas
bavrez oui Haron dit dans leopum des
intellectuels il montre bien que le
l'Occident est indissociable de deux
idées qui lui sont chères l'idée de la
liberté et puis l'idée de la la raison
et que c'est quand le l'Occident se
brouille avec ses idées que les que les
que les problèmes arrivent donc c'est
vrai que le 20e siècle a été celui du
suicide de l'Europe et c'est le ce sont
les États-Unis qui effectivement ont
fait la décision dans les trois guerres
mondiales y compris sur la fin de la la
guerre froide et Haron a vu aussi le
j'allais dire l'apogé de de l'Amérique
ce qu' a appelé la République impériale
et puis c'est le début de le début de le
début de ses difficultés ce qui est très
important c'est que il a construit à
partir de là euh une défense mais une
défense argumentée et critique de la
démocratie en ignorant pas ses
faiblesses ou ses vulnérabilités mais en
expliquant pourquoi elle devait être
défendue parce que c'était le seul moyen
d'assurer la dignité des hommes et
surtout en gardant toujours l'espoir
parce que ça a été rappelé euh Haron
MEUR en 83 donc c'est juste 6 ans avant
la l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique
mais Haron y compris dans les périodes
les plus difficiles a toujours gardé la
foi dans la démocratie c'est ce qu'il
disait en juin 39 je crois la victoire
finale des démocraties mais à une
condition c'est qu'elle le veuille et il
y a toujours cette cet engagement et et
aussi cette confiance cet acte de foi
dans la liberté et dans la capacité des
citoyens finalement à se mob disit il
reconnaît que les démocraties sont
traversées par beaucoup de
contradictions il sait comme toville
qu'en cas de guerre généralement ça
démarre mal pour les démocraties parce
que c'est des régimes qui sont
pacifistes et qui sont généralement qui
qui sous-estiment les menaces
extérieures mais il il il a il a foi
dans leurs ressources et dans leur
capacité à se mobiliser au moment où les
choses vont mal et c'est évidemment la
exactement la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouv aujourd'hui alors Sylvie
verman je sais qu'on peut pas parler à
la place d'Aron et lui faire commenter
le présent mais essayons Henry Kissinger
qui est décédé à la fin de
2023 dans une dernière interview dans Z
économiste à la question posée est-ce
que vous seriez favorable à ce que
l'Ukraine adhère à l'OTAN il a dit oui
est-ce que après avoir dit non très
longtemps oui après avoir dit non très
longtemps mais il a à ça à votre avis
qu'aurait pensé à Aaron parce que c'est
quand même le nous sommes là avec une
une menace en Europe donc je vous
demande pas de parler à la place d'Aron
mais à votre avis au regard de ce qu'il
a écrit de ce qu'il a dit de sa défense
de l'Europe de l'Occident et cetera oui
alors en même temps je voudrais ajouter
à ce qu'a dit Nicolas bavrz que il
croyait à la force de l'Occident mais
qu'en même temps il ne pensait pas que
l'Union soviétique allait effondré et
qu'il pronait le maintien de la
communication avec l'Union soviétique ce
qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui la
déconfliction pour éviter précis son
époque c'était l'Union soviétique voilà
euh
donc aujourd'hui je ne sais pas c'est
très c'est très compliqué parce que en
même temps pour l'Ukraine adhérer à
l'OTAN alors qu'elle n'a pas de
frontière qu'elle a une partie occupée
c'est totalement impossible et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement américain ne
l'a pas écouté puisqu'il s'est opposé à
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN mais un
jour peut-être effectivement mais c'est
très encore une fois je peux pas parler
à la place de de Raymond Aaron qui était
aussi bah très largement l'homme de la
guerre frine même s'il avait perçu que
la géopolitique allait s'élargir à
d'autres à d'autres pays et c'était à la
suite des des colonisations donc désolé
de vous décevoir mais difficile de
parler à la place des
morts
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir ce qui s'est
inscrit cette citation de Raymond Haron
si les philosophes ont souvent appelé
l'homme un être raisonnable ils ont
rarement appliquer avec la même
assurance ce qualificatif à l'histoire
des hommes alors Raymond Haron avait une
méfiance aussi réfléchie qu'instinctive
envers l'irrationalité de l'histoire à
votre avis d'où venait cette méfiance
chez lui est-ce qu'il craignait la
puissance des forces irrationnel la
violence les passions des foules Nicolas
Baverez c'est pas qu'il les craignait
mais c'est qu'il les reconnaissait pour
ce qu'elles sont quand on regarde penser
la guerre closuswiitz on a bien ce
mouvement entre d'un côté on l'a rappelé
le rôle des des leaders des dirigeants
politiques des stratèges ensuite il y a
des des des processus historiques qui
sont très longs et puis ensuite il y a
les passions des peuples et ces passions
des peuples il y a la passion nationale
il peut y avoir des passions collectives
qui les embarquent euh du côté du du
racisme ce qu'on a vu avec le euh
l'Allemagne et aujourd'hui on le voit
aussi avec des avec des des des passions
religieuses donc le en fait Aaron euh
nous explique justement comment essayer
de de réagir et comment essayer de
de préserver la liberté politique dans
dans ces environnements qui sont par
ailleurs des configurations qui changent
c'est pour répondre aussi à ce que vousz
la question que vous posiez tout à
l'heure dans le système d'Aron il y a le
système international il y a les États
et les société les États sont les sont
les pivots et donc il y a bien cette
reconnaissance du fait que l'histoire
elle est faite de projet de vision de
raison et et et que il faut défendre la
raison et la liberté mais quelle est
fait aussi des des passions et et pour
revenir à l'époque présente et et à
cette idée de ce que les hommes sont
raisonnable euh en 1960 à Londres il a
prononcé une conférence assez
extraordinaire sur l'aube de l'histoire
universelle ou d'une certaine manière il
anticipe la fin de l'Union soviétique en
montrant que les hommes vont être dans
la même histoire qui est une histoire
universelle c'est celle dans laquelle
nous vivons et il termine cette
conférence en disant jamais les hommes
n'ont eu autant de raisons de ne plus
s'entretuer jamais ils n'ont eu autant
de raisons de travailler ensemble et
pourtant est-ce que l'histoire universel
sera pacifique sans doute non et il
termine avec cette phrase l'homme est un
être raisonnable mais les hommes le
sont-il et on a bien cette de cette
nature et et cet espoir que la raison
finisse par pouvoir réconcilier les
hommees mais que la réalité c'est que ce
ce les les les passions doivent être
reconnu pour eu oui ben alors justement
sur ce point pierre manant entre l'homme
raisonnable l'histoire
irrationnel est-ce qu'il rejoint en
quelque sorte Freud qui disait que
l'homme dès qu'il va vers la
multitude il n'y a pas d'autre choix que
de s'entretuer et aux civilisations de
s'autodétruire qu'est-ce comment vous
explique que Haron dirait ce genre de
chose oui mais est-ce qu'il est pas sur
cette même non mais simplement je sur
cette même lignée non mais il n'a jamais
rêvé de la paix de la paix euh
universelle euh il était qu'ancien
pourtant oui beaucoup moins qu'on le dit
euh beaucoup moins qu'on le dit il était
plutôt aristotélicien
ou ou tucididéen il il partait de la de
la pluralité des corps politiques donc
nécessairement euh comme les hommes ne
réalisent leur humanité que dans des
corps politiques distinctes
nécessairement euh ces corps vont vont
être entre eux dans des relations soit
d'amitié soit d'hostilité et il
pensaient que cette fragmentation de
l'humanité était insurmontable et d'une
certaine façon qu'elle ne doit pas être
surmontée parce que autrement la seule
façon de le surmonter ce serait d'avoir
un État mondial qui serait
nécessairement despotique donc si l'on
si l'on désire la liberté on doit
accepter le risque de la vie politique
le risque de communautés distinctes qui
ont chacune non seulement des intérêts
mais comme Aaron l'a toujours
souligné ce sont moins les intérêts qui
sépart les hommes que leurs idées du
bien et que leur que leurs opinions donc
même si on on peut s'accorder sur le
fait que toute guerre est contre les
intérêts de tout le monde finalement
mais c'est pas pour ça que cel empêchera
les hommes de se de se battre donc les
paramètres de la vie humaine sont à la
fois les intérêts les les opinions les
passions rison d'une humanité
réconciliée mais la réalité d'une
humanité fragmentée et c'est de avec
tout cela que le l'homme politique le
citoyen doit se débrouiller donc Haron
ne s'est jamais laissé emporter par une
par une solution qui qui viendrait
malgré nous en quelque sorte parce que
l'histoire nous conduirait à la
réconciliation parce que les le commerce
nous conduirait à la paix il savait
toujours qu'au bout du compte ce sont
des hommes avec des des opinions
distinctes des passions sans lesqueles
il ne vivrait pas et puis des
incertitudes qui que l'on ne peut que
l'on ne peut ôter de la vie humaine donc
il gardait une vue dramatique si vous
voulez de de de de l'existence humaine
et je reviens d'un mot à l'Europe dont
nous parlions il me semble me souvenir
que un des points qui qui qui revenait
sous sa plume quand il parlait de
l'Europe il était surpris de voir à quel
point l'Europe était devenue
spectatrice de ce qui se passait dans le
monde elle était au onte l'histoire et
il il n'arrivait pas à comprendre en
quelque sorte à quel qu'elle qu'elle
laisse à ce point l'action aux
États-Unis ou aux autres puissances et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous nous posons
encore cette question pi Lelou je
voulais intervenir non mais je je
partage totalement ce que Pierre Manan a
dit j'ajouterai un ou deux éléments le
premier c'est que c'était l'homme de son
époque hein c'est c'était quelqu'un qui
avait connu la guerre qui avait connu la
montée du nazisme et qui avait connu la
guerre c'est c'est une très grande
différence de cette génération qui est
aussi celle de
mitteran bien sûr de Charles de Gaul
quand vous comparez ça au au au leader
ou dirigeant actuels pas seulement en
France mais en Europe et que vous les
voyez comment ils se comportent dans une
affaire aussi grave que l'Ukraine
basculement du monde que nous vivons
aujourd'hui c'est là qu'il y a un
problème si vous voulez on a
l'impression qu'il y a pas de profondeur
ces gens n'ont pas la profondeur
historique qui ressemble vraiment au au
somnambule de Christopher
Clark au moment de la première guerre
mondiale ils ont juste pas compris ce
qui se passe c'est l'impression que ça
me donne et qui me qui m'effraie
d'ailleurs euh avec des gens comme Aaron
ou de GA ou mitterran ou ces gens qui
avaient vécu cette périodelà ils avaient
intériorisé l'idée que des peuples
peuvent disjoncter faire la guerre que
ça peut être extrêmement violent et
difficile c'est la réalité la deuxième
la conséquence de ça c'est qu'il a
fabriqué il a été un de ceux qui ont
construit ce qu'on appelle l'école
réaliste des analyses de la politique
internationale Kissinger se reconnaît en
hararon parce que c'est des gens dont je
fais partie je pense que d'autres ici
aussi analyse le monde tel qu'il est pas
tel que monsieur Kouchner aimerait qu'il
soit avec son sac de riz sur l'épaule ou
faisant des on est la France n'est pas
une ONG on n'est pas dans le monde du du
bisounours on est de devant des rapports
de force très complexes avec en plus
l'apparition de de tout un tas de
méchants révisionnistes qui profitant de
la fin de la guerre froide et du du tâ
de la près-gerre froide sont en train de
faire exploser le système et et et là on
peut en effet se désespérer de voir dans
quel état aujourd'hui l'Europe se trouve
et je pense que Aaron lui multiplierait
les papiers
extraordinairement durs sur mais
qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train de
laisser faire ce que certains d'entre
nous ici essayent de faire mais mais moi
je
suis dans dans ce que m'a appris Aaron
lui-même ses lectures et puis mes amis
autour de lui c'est qu'on doit être
extrêmement vigilant sur ce qui se passe
et essayer de redonner un peu de un peu
de colonne
vertébrale à la façon de gérer le monde
la principale leçon qu'il faut garder
d'arond dans cette période extrêmement
troublée où nous sommes c'est la
compréhension réaliste de ce qui de ce
qui est devant nous sans se cacher en
appelant un chat à un chat et
deuxièmement avoir le courage ensuite de
dire bon voilà il faut qu'on fasse ça je
donne un exemple puis après je me tais
quand on est dans une situation où la
guerre est de retour en Europe depuis 2
ans que c'est catastrophique que les les
on tire des milliers de buts tous les
jours 6000 par jour en Ukraine l'Ukraine
les Russes beaucoup plus quand on voit
l'état de notre industrie d'armement des
lois de des des des budgets de défense
qui ont été voté y compris la loi de
programmation militaire française voulez
dire qu'on est pas préparé mais mais
mais on a l'impression de mettre des
lunettes noires juste pas voir et pas se
préparer au monde tel qu'il est et ça
c'est grave et c'est là je pense que
Aaron aurait écrit des trucs très durs
comme il avait écrit au moment de la
crise de Cuba et autres voilà ça la
réalité Jean-Claude Casan oui mais je
suis nous avons publié dans commentaire
un article d'Aron qui est une conférence
qu'il a prononcé en 1969 et que je
trouve d'une remarquable actualité en 69
bonpidou vient de prendre le ou voir en
France Haron a critiqué la politique
étrangère du général de Gaulle à l'égard
de l'Union soviétique de 64 à la mort du
général de Gaulle et politique qui avait
d'ailleurs été annulée si j'ose dire par
la réinvasion de la Tchécoslovaquie en
1978 alors que dit Aaron en 69 Aaron dit
en
69 la puissance nucléaire soviétique
oblige l'Europe à être protégée par la
puissance nucléaire américaine
l'Europe peut se satisfaire de cette
situation mais elle est confortable mais
regrettable elle est confortable parce
qu'évidemment on dépense beaucoup moins
pour l'armement puisque les États-Unis
le font à autre place regrettable parce
que d'une certaine façon l'Europe perd
sa souveraineté et son existence
historique et si vous transposez à la
situation actuelle dans la situation
actuelle l'Europe vis-à-vis de la Russie
est faible conventionnellement alors que
nous sommes quatre fois plus peup
que nous avons une puissance
industrielle supérieure à celle de la
Russie donc nous pourrions avoir une
dissuasion
conventionnelle supérieure à celle de la
Russie et Haron a toujours soutenu le
nucléaire militaire français et le
nucléaire militaire anglais et
explicitement dans son article il laisse
entendre que l'Europe pourrait également
se donner une dissuation nucléaire
c'est-à-dire que l'Europe sera
souveraine lorsqu'elle aura une
dissuation nucléaire une une disuation
conventionnelle et il y a dans cet
article une un profond regret est-ce que
l'Europe veut rester au balcon de
l'histoire c'est une expression d'Aron
est-ce que l'Europe veut rester au B au
balcon de l'histoire ou être pour parti
protégé par des puissances extérieures
qui peut-être d'ailleurs puisque ce
profil l'élection de Trump cesseront
d'être protectrices alors Sylvie Berman
à qui la faute alors et en même temps
est-ce qu'Aron a influencé la diplomatie
française mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure effectivement je crois que
beaucoup de de diplomates sont devenus
aroniens parce que c'était la raison
c'était la logique effectivement est-ce
qu'il a oui c'est une vision du monde
maintenant en ce qui concerne l'action
c'est vrai qu'il y a une faiblesse
européenne c'est pas le le fait de la
France hein même le président Macron a
voulu pousser pour une défense
européenne une autonomie stratégique
mais on se heurte à d'autres pays quand
à la dissuasion nucléaire il avait été
évoqué la possibilité pour la France de
partager justement la dissuasion
nucléaire mais vous avez des pays
profondément antinucléaire même
antinucléaire civil donc ça ça c'est
c'est ils changeront on l'espère mais en
tout cas ça prendra du temps on voit
arriver Trump ce qui est une probabilité
très forte on ne sait pas si une finé
c'est ce qui se passera est-ce qu'on s'y
prépare non on commment on déploore mais
on s'y prépare pas vraiment mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire s'y préparer
d'avoir un budget défense beaucoup plus
important d'avoir un budget défense plus
important d'avoir une base industrielle
de la défense également des
capacités est-ce que vous savez qu'on en
est réduit aujourd'hui pardon je coupe
mais juste un mot la France l'Angleterre
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui c'est moins de
200 chars de combat en état de marche
chacun moins de 200 puisquils n'ont pas
la possibilité d'armer l'Ukraine il il y
a voilà on en est réduit à ça au bout de
30 ans de désarmement budgétaire
unilatéral oui vous exemple je vous
laisse poursuivre alors la décision a
été prise de fournir 1 million Deb à
l'Ukraine on en a fourni 300000
seulement donc il y a oui an on devait
fabriquer 1 million en un an absolument
et on en a fabriqué 300000 et donc il y
a ce problème là c pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en a fabriqué 300000 pourquoi parce que
une industrie de défense pour engager
des chaînes de production de d'obu ou de
quoi que ce soit d'autre a besoin de
contrat à long terme pour acheter les
équipements pour engager des gens or
tous les budget de l'Europe actuelle
sont insuffisants pour relancer les
sites de production et c'est pour ça
qu'on a plus d'industrie de défense donc
tout tout ce que vous entendez c'est
pardon c'est du pipo par rapport à la
gravité de ce qui se passe en face et de
ce qui peut arriver demain aux
États-Unis l'Europe elle est euh encore
plus faible qu'elle a jamais été alors
si je puis dire retournant à à Aaron bon
le constat vous l'avez fait là sur
l'insuffisante préparation de l'Europe
qui explique par ailleurs pourquoi cette
Europe n'est pas une puissance euh
Rémont Aron disait à l'époque de la
guerre froide pai impossible guerre
improbable j'aimerais bien que vous
explicitiez ce que ça veut dire et
est-ce qu'on est dans un retour à la
guerre air froide aujourd'hui parce que
on se retrouve devant un contexte plus
conflictuel que jamais c'est
effectivement le la formule qu'il avait
utilisé dans un livre qui date de 47 et
pour définir la situation et et et avant
même qui j'allais dire l'équilibre de la
terreur qui a rendu cette formule encore
plus juste donc P impossible pourquoi
parce que les deux systèmes idéologique
et politique étaiit irréductiblement
opposé et qui avait pas de compromis ou
d'accord vraiment possible et guerre
improbable pourquoi parce que
effectivement euh la oui mais la guerre
est là maintenant oui non mais ça c'est
ça c'est l'explication de de de de la
situation de la guerre froide des fin
des années 40 début des années 50
ensuite après la chute de l'Union
soviétique on s'est retrouvé dans un
système où on a cru pour le coup que la
paix était perpétuelle et la guerre
était impossible c'était une illusion
pure il suffisait de voir ce qui se
passait dans la réalité notamment à avec
une Russie sous l'autorité de Vladimir
Poutine qui a été en réalité en guerre
permanente et la guerre fait partie de
est au principe du du régime de de
Vladimir Poutine et Haron ne se serait
certainement pas trompé sur la nature
réelle en tout cas du régime du régime
russe et aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
système j'allais dire qui est le système
que je définira de la manière suivante
la paix est de nouveau impossible nous
avons de nouveau une
irréductible des systèmes politiques qui
sont en guerre en lutte à mort avec euh
euh la Chine de xijinping avec la Russie
de Poutine avec aussi des théocraties on
l'oublie toujours mais l'Iran
l'Afghanistan et et et euh les
djihadistes qui vont avec donc la paix
est impossible mais la guerre est
omniprésente on sous-estime le fait que
depuis 1945 il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'État en guerre qu'aujourd'hui et ça
c'est ce que les européens ne veulent
pas voir ce qui a été rappelé par euh
euh et et et qui est une c'est
incroyable on a un président de la
République qui utilise les mots de
réarmement mais qui n'en fait rien et là
c'est une autre chose que nous dirons
c'est que quand les mots jurent autant
avec les choses et avec la réalité de ce
qu'on fait j'ai ça se finit toujours
très mal et donc il est très important
pour les Européens mais aussi pour la
France de remettre les mots en face avec
les faits et avec la la politique parce
que l'économie de guerre pour le coup
elle existe en Russie elle n'existe
absolument pas chez nous merci alors
pierre Lelouche là-dessus alors sur P
impossible guerre improbable je crois
que l'équation demeure quand même
c'estàdire que ni la Russie les
États-Unis veulent d'un affrontement
direct d'ailleurs il se garde bien de de
dépasser le seuil d'une guerre par
procuration en Ukraine
euh en revanche ce qui est beaucoup plus
problématique c'est que maintenant il y
a beaucoup d'acteurs dans le dans le
système une des conséquences de cette
guerre en Ukraine que personnellement je
trouve complètement absurde depuis le
début on aurait pu l'éviter on a choisi
de pas l'éviter les Américains on hésité
finalement ils sont allés enfin bref on
est dans un dans un système qui en effet
quand même un pays occupé pierre Lelou
oui enfin c'est ni le
premier prier ni le dernier P
up près de 20 % de son territoire et
vous savez bien que l'impérialisme russe
est d'abord territorial c'est une leçon
de oui mais la question c'est de savoir
si c'est un mais c'est pas le sujet de
notre émission oui non mais justement
Aaron aurait probablement essayé de
comprendre le pourquoi du command de
cette guerre et c'est c'est ce qui n'a
pas été fait je je dis que cette guerre
est d'abord une guerre émotionnelle on
est engagé dedans pour un tas de raisons
on pense que milliers de morts que mais
alors l'Ukraine est une ligne de
fracture on peut pas on va pas
cristalliser là-dessus
mais plutôt parlons sur ce que je crois
que ce que ce qu' sans doute dire pierre
Lelouche et sur lequel on est tous
d'accord c'est que cette guerre
d'Ukraine avec en plus qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre c'est qu' un effet de
libération de la violence voilà ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que nous avons
réussi à faire avec cette affaire tout
le monde he Poutine compris
naturellement je suis pas là pour dire
qu'il a pas envahi il a envahi oui la
façon dans cette affaire a été gérée
c'est qu'à la fin de la journée nous
nous avons réalisé le cauchemar de
Kissinger et sans doute de Aaron qui est
de fabriquer une alliance entre la
Russie et la Chine avec deux autres
puissances nucléaires potentielles
encore plus dingue qui sont l'Iran et la
Corée du Nord donc du point de vue des
intérêts stratégiques de l'Europe
permettez-moi de vous dire que cette
situation est probablement la pire
possible à partir de là un jour ou
l'autre il va falloir essayer de
désescalader et trouver la solution
alors je vais revenir si vous voulez
bienon parce qu'il nous reste très très
peu de temps que chacun dise un mot
là-dessus si vous voulez je sais que
c'est le cosmopolitisme d'Aron en
faisait un lecteur aussi passionné de
Tuy did que de Marx est-ce que à votre
avis Rémond araron était-il aussi sujet
aux doutes et réceptif aux
contradictions dont it disait que
c'était un principe de sagesse alors
piermanant très brièvement là-dessus je
sais que c'est une question importante
mais ça nous permet de conclure et que
chacun dise un mot sur la personnalité
d'Aron qu'on voudrait disons être trop
raisonnable par rapport au côté trop
rêveur de Jean-Paul
Sartre en un mot je sais que c'est
difficile mais ça nous permet de cerner
le personnage écoutez par qu'il était
sujet au doutes je je pense qu'il il il
avait toujours il avait toujours peur de
se tromper c'est pourquoi il se trompait
moins que les autres c'est une très
bonne formule mais il était passionné et
il le savait c'est et pourquoi il
faisait un si grand effort pour
surmonter surmonter sa passion donc pour
moi Aaron c'est comment dire euh si si
j'ose
dire c'est le citoyen par excellence le
grand citoyen par excellence
c'est-à-dire qui est mu par la passion
du bien commun et par un désir alors la
passionné de de comprendre les ressort
de de l'histoire humaine comment comment
nous nous nous débrouillons pour
conduire ses vies qui sont à la fois
calamiteuses et parfois splendides donc
c'est c'est ainsi
que que je le vois Jean-Claude Casanova
un homme qui doute aussi CIS il a
beaucoup étudié Marx mais il aurait
préféré étudier autre chose il a
beaucoup étudié Marx parce que à partir
de Marx étrangement d'ailleurs l'Union
soviétique était devenue une puissance
impérialiste qui dominait la moitié de
l'Europe la moitié la moitié de Berlin
la moitié de l'Europe absolument le
grand vainqueur de la 2uxe guerre
mondial c'est Staline qui a d'une
certaine façon donné à la Russie une
puissance qu'elle n'avait jamais connu
dans son histoire et tout ça au nom
d'une religion créée à partir de Marx et
qui devait pas s'appliquer à la Russ et
donc il a il a beaucoup il a beaucoup
étudié mais il aurait préféré autre
chose un mot là-dessus l'homme qui doute
l'homme du doute oui puisque la plupart
des gens font de leur mémoire un
exercice d'autocélébration les mémoires
d'Aron c'est la manière dont il utilise
son esprit critique pour revoir sa
trajectoire et sa pensée et l'autre mot
c'est générosité y compris avec ses
adversaires non seulement il les
respecte mais si on regarde par exemple
Sartre c'est celui qui est qui qui
réhabilite le vrai Sartre face à la à
Benny Levi oui absolument merci
écoutez je suis désolé d'interrompre
cette conversation fort intéressante
notamment sur personne âge aussi
passionnant que rmoiron mais le temps
imparti est écoulé alors je voudrais
vous présenter une brève bibliographie
alors évidemment on peut retrouver toute
l'œuvre de Raymont Haron paix guerre
entre les nations qui a été publiée chez
kalalman Levi ses mémoires chez Robert
Lafond l'opium des intellectuels enfin
tout ce que vous voulez Nicolas bavrez
vous avez également
publié une biographie de Raymond Haron
iste autant des idéologies c'était pas
c'est paru chez Périn en un mot
qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu montrer en
un mot j'ai voulu montrer précisément
que le j'allais dire le courage et le
fait que le courage n'est pas réservé
aux homme d'action il peut aussi être
celui des intellectuels vous savez c'est
le fameux discours de solgidine le
déclin du courage avec Aaron on a
quelqu'un qui a montré qu'il y avait pas
de déclin du courage merci Sylvie Berman
alors vous avez été ambassadeur ap
à Moscou vous avez publié une vie de
diplomate ça vous a servi beaucoup
d'être à la fois à Pékin et à Moscou
pour comprendre le monde
commeectatri engag ce sont des
diplomates engagé ce sont des acteurs
déterminants et surtout j'ai connu des
périodes charnières c'est j'ai connu la
fin de l'Union soviétique à l'époque de
gorbachchov la fin de la guerre froide
j'ai connu la période Poutine ensuite
j'ai j'ai étais étudiante même en Chine
en 76 c'estàdire à la fin de la
Révolution
culturelle
merilleement et puis sidingping aussi
donc oui c'est fondamental pour
comprendre le monde aujourd'hui voilà
alors Jean-Claude Casanova vous avez
publié de nombreux livres dont un livre
de giscar à mitteran donc là c'est
contemporain presque contemporain de
mitteran vous trouvez que les hommes
politiques ont été influencés par rmont
Haron un peu pas passionnément pas du
tout peu je crois dans la période
certainement si vous voulez giscar d'une
certaine façon il lisait beaucoup Paron
et Pompidou d'une certaine façon aussi
et de Gaul au moment de l'Alliance
atlantique mais je voudrais rappeler un
mot d'Aaron parce que Sartre avait dit
un jour aaron est admirateur et avec SAR
disait ça avec mépris parce qu'il
n'était pas spontanément admirateur et
Aaron invoquait toujours la la formule
d'Alain la l'admiration et la
consolation des fors c'est-à-dire que la
capacité d'admirer est une forme de
générosité tandis que le
ressentiment crée la le besoin de merci
de rappel cette choseel alors pierre
bant votre dernier livre c'est Pascal et
la proposition chrétienne on n pas le le
temps d'en parler mais vous diriez que
Aaron était pascalien d'une ça vous
choque de dire ça non ça ne ça ne me
choque pas tokville qui était quand même
un de ses une de ses grandes lectures
était c'était explicitement pascalien
non je en même temps je pense que Aaron
avait respect pour la religion respect
pour le christianisme mais en même temps
ce n'était pas une âme naturellement
naturellement religieuse il je ne dirais
pas que c'est un homme qui était
tourmenté par la question religieuse
mais à coup sûr comme il le dit
euh de façon assez mémorable son sa
détestation des religions séculières lui
a donné un certain respect pour les
religions régulière dont parlait Nicolas
merci Pierre Manan alors pierre Leloup
je rappelle que vous avez écrit une
guerre sans fin et il semblerait que
nous soyons dans une
conflictualisation sans fin si vous êtes
partagz ce pessimisme là sur un autre
livre I en ce moment justement sur la
Phe suivante mais malheureusement euh
l'Institut stratégique de Londres l'an
dernier en 2023 a dénombré 120 183
conflits hors hors la guerre de Gaza 183
conflits donc on est en plein dedans
merci alors je voudrais vous remercier
Madame messieur d'avoir participer à
cette émission je voudrais remercier
l'équipe d'lcp et avant de vous nous
quitter je vous soumets cette pensée de
Raymond Haron la liberté et l'essence de
la culture occidentale le fondement de
sa réussite le secret de son étendue et
de son influence
[Musique]
merci